what aspects of the methyl gaming poker
is most difficult to master I think the
most difficult thing for people is
self-awareness
right and resilience self-awareness to
know okay so you know again is it am I
am I not doing as well as I could be
because of luck or is there things that
I can learn and I always look to
mistakes as opportunities I really do
when I make a mistake in a poker hand
right call it a breakdown or whatever
that's where breakthroughs happen we're
like oh you know what I could have done
here I could have done this and that
would have been really good and I'm
going to do that going forward so I
think like with anything
um you know when you start out playing
golf like your goal is to just hit the
ball right then you try to hit it in the
air then you're trying to hit it
straight then you're trying to hit it on
the green then you're trying to hit it
closer to the green to the point where
the pros get where you know they're so
finite they're trying to hit it 63 yards
and spin it back three yards they're in
it's imperfect like they don't hit the
perfect shot because the perfect shot
for them is it goes in but they try and
make the mistakes smaller and smaller
and smaller poker is the same
we all make mistakes consistently the
goal is to minimize especially the big
ones
what was the lowest point for you
psychologically
in poker in general actually maybe it
was this year maybe it was in general do
you remember there was times in your
life speaking of resilience that were
extremely difficult to you mentally
yeah so early on you know as basically
as you know as a teenager I was playing
Toronto and then in my early 20s I'm
like I'm going to Vegas right and I
thought I was the best 21 years old I'm
like check me out right show up with
three thousand dollars 24 hours later
you know money's gone and I remember I
remember the moment vividly it was at
the Binion's horse it was about three in
the morning I was playing with seven
other people you know I lost my last
chips I went to the bathroom washed up
got out they all left and it was like a
moment where I realized like okay in
Toronto I was the big fish but here they
were playing because of me I was the
sucker I remembered every one of their
faces and then I remember not having
enough money to get back to Budget
Suites where I was staying so
I walked I didn't you know I walked and
in that moment I was thinking about like
is this something that I'll be able to
do am I good enough you know what am I
going to do now I'm in Vegas I don't
know anybody and I have no money right
so that was certainly like what felt
like a low Point walking back behind
paradise and Twain which is not a great
part of town
uh where did you find the the strength
to answer yes to that question that you
can you can still do good I think this
has been sort of a pattern in my life
where like in the evening after it
happens like I don't have it you know I
don't have that feeling of Hope or you
know resilience if you will I'm allowing
myself to experience despair which is
exactly where I'm at but then a good
night's sleep wake up the next morning
and just within me I have that inner
confidence to say you know what [ __ ] it
get back on the hobby horse find a way
make it work right and I but I do
believe it's really therapeutic and
worthwhile to allow yourself to feel and
vent so many people today the Instagram
culture world I call it it's like they
want to act like they're perfect nothing
bothers them [ __ ] right you're
pissed off it's okay to show it emotions
fine we all have it there's no reason
you have to suppress it obviously you
don't want to have guys throwing selfie
sticks around the room every time they
lose a pot right yeah but but you know a
little to make everybody feel unsafe
yeah yeah exactly that happens so you're
saying there is a culture saying you
know stay positive all this kind of
stuff but you know when you feel despair
don't resist it write it out because it
doesn't go away right that feeling you
know you think you put it away in the
pit of your stomach and you think you
know it's gone it's not it's still there
let yourself go [ __ ] yeah you know it's
all right you know there's nothing wrong
with being a little bit emotional
because once you've experienced it you
let it out
now you can move past it yeah and I feel
like as long as your brain chemistry can
support it uh you can usually learn a
good lesson from it like you become
stronger you become more resilient
through it it's really interesting and a
good night's sleep can really help
absolutely yeah